CFE cotisation foncière des entreprises
trois lettres qui ont fait bondir les
commerces incontinois cette contribution
entrée en remplacement de la taxe
professionnelle s'avère pour certains
petits commerçants et bien plus lourdes
que prévu avec des cotisations qui ont
doublé voire triplés depuis l'année
dernière je dis soir réunis en conseil
syndical les élus de l'agglomération ont
fait voter une motion à l'unanimité pour
leur permettre de modifier la
délibération du 22 septembre 2011 qui
fixait les modalités cette motion se
traduira en vote lors du prochain
conseil syndical le 18 décembre en
attendant des consignes ont été données
par la Direction des finances pour
permettre plus de souplesse dans le
paiement de la cotisation et les
commerçants de leur côté manifesteront
demain mardi à 15h30 devant l'hôtel
d'agglomération